head over to the best song ever.com and
purchase our new hit together again it
is a cover of smoky Mike in the god king
that's Jeremy boring and Michael nolles
and with your help we will smash our way
onto the Billboard charts we've got this
ladies and gentlemen I am going to say
this unequivocally Ronda santis has
disqualified himself there is no
circumstance in which I will vote for
this man what are you g him you going to
get him off the ballot no no he he can
do whatever want
take a look at this video let me play it
for you and you can hear it for yourself
do we have audio C up and real quick
fellow GOP 2024 presidential candidate
Vic ramaswami saying he will remove
himself from the Colorado ballot unless
Trump's eligibility is restored would
you do the
same no I think that's just playing into
the left um I think the case will get
overturned by the Supreme Court but I've
qualified for all the ballots I'm
competing in all the states and I'm
going to accumulate the delegates
necessary that's the whole name of the
game in this situation but I do
anticipate that that decision was
political and will get
reversed all right governor for that he
has disqualified himself do you know
what VI is really really good at V is
really good maybe this he's read too
much Robert Green 48 loss of power he's
really good at making these bold power
moves and forcing everyone else to react
to what he's doing that to me is
political strategy that its finest we
have to address this Ronda Santa says
that's playing into the left it makes no
sense it literally makes no sense makes
no sense the move of the left is to
remove Donald Trump so that someone else
wins the primary Ron said I know what
they did is political and I have secured
the delegates and that's the game and if
you want to be really pedantic the
California Supreme Court and the left
are not synonymous because there's lots
of leftists Colorado Supreme Court sorry
Colorado there's lots of leftists who
are I know like people on Twitter freak
out there's lots of leftists who are pro
democracy in this sense who find this
uncontable I I I will call out look Tu
robt Kenny Jr is not a right- Winger
he's like this is crazy tuck Carlson
said on IRL on Monday at tpusa that the
people representing Ron desandis online
are some of the nastiest zero some
people he's ever seen and instantly they
all lose their minds can you name names
cuz who's he referring to well because
someone I'm friends with like Laura
lommer I like Laura right she goes for
the juggler every time does she work for
Trump no no I'm chrisa Pasa okay she's
Ron second in command sure she she she
she on the internet behaves as though
she and Laura lummer are the exact same
person doing the exact same things okay
and now at first I said now hold on
there just gosh darn minute in that
voice in that voice Laura lomer is just
a fan of trump right and Christina Pasha
is is Ron's second in command for what
reason is the the like press campaign
press secretary and second in command
arguing with fans of Donald Trump and
that's the world they live in so at
first I say this doesn't reflect on on
on the santis in ter terms of the
nastiness of his supporters online but
the fact that he won't fire them
absolutely does so when Tucker said it
doesn't reflect on Ron but these people
are B absolutely does of course why
won't he fire red fern Griffin and and
Pasha if Ian was on on Twitter like
spouting Nazi ideology and you're going
to be like well it's his opinion like
that's crazy depending but I got to be
honest like we have a very strong Free
Speech Ben company but you're you're
right and I've said this over and over
again there is a threshold I'm willing
to tolerate I I I I have said free
speech not for those who don't believe
in free speech anybody wants to come in
here advocate for fascism and taking
away people's rights I'm going to say
I'm not going to defend yours you don't
at least I'm not at least I don't have
to hire you it's freedom of Association
you hire and work whoever you want yeah
Ronda Sanz is here he said it the the
last part of this is the most important
part not the I won't remove myself
whatever the last part of this is what
matters let me play it
again no I think that's just playing
into the left um I think that that was
meaningless by the way makes no sense
yeah but anyway will get overturned by
the Supreme Court but I've qualified for
all the ballots I'm competing in all the
states and I'm going to accumulate the
delegates necessary that's the whole
name of the game in this situation the
whole name of the game is for him to
accumulate the delegates he will not
remove himself even if Trump has has
been removed he thinks Trump will be put
back on it's political I'm getting all
these desandis people saying oh yeah but
you know he's saying he knows it'll be
overturned like that's meaningless if
that were true and he thought 100% Trump
would be back on the ballot then he
would say viv's right I I will
absolutely remove myself from the
primary process because it's not a real
race no he said the opposite he said the
name of the game is getting delegates
and I'm not backing down I'm going to
win he he is no different than a
Democrat I have seen not one time in
this primary where Ronda santis did a
bold move or took a strong stand on
anything which is shocking to me no it
would have been more interesting if he
beat V to the punch here right because
that's the thing now vake who knows
everyone else there he we talk about all
the time Republicans are not Unified
there are a bunch of people who
obviously don't want Trump to become the
nominee theoretically included right
because he's campaigning for president
so he was the first one to say well I
would leave it and now all of them who
actually don't want to leave the race
either follow suit meaning that he is
the leader or they argue and then they
see antitrump which isolates the base
his entire governorship is bold move
bold move leftist freak out headline
bold move bold move bold move but as but
he's running as you would think a Nikki
Haley candidacy be run he's running
worse than Nikki Haley worse but I mean
I don't understand and
what I see is I didn't support Donald
Trump in 2016 I we have criticisms on
this show of trump we have debates over
police as an institution abolition of
police we have we have fairly nuanced
conversations the left doesn't want to
come on the show well screw them they
don't have to but they should and when
it comes to the likes of Donald Trump as
I said uh Luke rowski will come on here
and criticize Trump to no end even at
one point saying he wouldn't vote for
him and then he sure enough went and
voted for him Luke voted Luke says he
voted for Trump
okay I guess I guess we know who the
real Anarchist is after all that's right
that's right but my point is this me
Michael you have yeah your brother I
hate him you have Ronda sanz's
supporters prominent journalists and
personalities and person as at the daily
wire who are saying things that come off
as the most
pathetic desperate lies to defend Ronda
Sanz Matt Walsh said something that I
thought was just it was cringe he
criticized V saying what's the point of
doing this blah blah blah and I'm like
it is the most unbelievable thing and
inauthentic thing a person could say
acting as though they don't understand
what VI was doing right we all get it VI
is in third place in the Lesser known
GOP debates he's in fourth place in the
primary and he's still doing power moves
and we know exactly why he's doing it to
act like you think it makes no sense is
in my opinion it's cringe man there
there there are journalists that we've
had on the show
obviously we're friends with Matt we I
like the guy I think he's fantastic but
I'll criticize who I think deserves it
and they're they're on Twitter Dave ruin
acting like Ronda sand just did the
right thing here and I'm like dude I
don't care what you think okay we can be
friends we can have dinner that's kind
of the point but no one believes you
when you come out and you're like I
think Ron did the right thing you don't
believe that now you're losing all your
credibility because he's outright saying
he's going to win the delegates after
they removed Trump from the race and
that's the game no it isn't and here's
the thing isn't Colorado way down the
line in terms of when they actually
super Tuesday yeah so like Colorado is
not going to be determinative in any
case by super Tuesday it's probably
going to be close to wrapped up maybe
down to two people right so this
wouldn't even cost them anything else if
he on the other hand let's play devil
I'll me let me play devil Devil's ADV
with you what if the concern with d
santis is that vake is being the leader
among the plan B people and if Ron
agrees with him that's going to be used
as look Ronda Santa can't even leave
with within the primary yep and and V at
least in the 538 polls uh after the last
debate he jumped over Christie Christy
and he were sort of neck and neck and he
he's jumped W as bad for he must have
had some kind of big pogo stick I think
part yeah that's true but those extreme
pogos oh yeah where they do flips and
stuff that's super cool I think part of
it is that V has uh Charisma and when
he's on stage he can really command
attention right he had his like got
nothing to lose right and so at this
point why not I mean the thought what I
heard from some people was like it's
easy to say I'll come off the ballot
when you think they're going to
terminate their campaign anyways which
also puts him in a strong position it's
one of the reasons that people want
Donald Trump back in the white house
because he could only serve one more
term anyways so imagine what he would do
uh it's a very similar mindset and I
think again that's a threat to santis
let me give you an example Ryan cedra he
said in response I said I I tweeted no
one SE no one honest sees anything other
than Ron trying to win power if he
really believed it he would uh it would
be overturned he would agree with v
sedra tweeted one Trump's team filed a
lawsuit to have disantis thrown off the
ballot which Tim Po ignores this is why
I despise these people sorry Ryan this
is the cringiest most despicable thing
is Ryan a dis santis person yes okay
when this happened we all talked about
it you want me to go back to May and be
like well I know it's happening now with
Trump but let's go back in time six
months to discuss an old news story
that's not relevant right now well of
course we talked about it whenever these
stories come up we talk about it the
whole debate we had was over whether or
not first it's whether Ron could be
Trump's VP that that's out of the
question and whether or not Ron was in
violation of laws pertaining to using
his funds from from from the governor's
race for the presidential race and we've
had numerous conversations about his
staff working between the campaign and
his uh and his office that conversation
happens all the time and now he's like
Tim ignores it they're just lying and
anyone hold on let me let I don't know
Ryan but let it could be that he just
doesn't know so he doesn't mean he's
lying he just could be ignorant why is
he bringing up a story from May because
in this case it's showing that he's
trying to claim that Trump's being a
hypocrite so he's claiming I'm a
hypocrite no he he could be ignores he
could be playing that in terms of him
not knowing your record as opposed to
lying so he's making instead of looking
into it at all correct he maybe he was
lazy so he's fabricating or lazy I I I I
I don't accept lazy okay that's fine
considering considering the fact that
Ron's supporters have this this is their
ammo this is one example as well as you
do okay this is no matter what Ron does
there's some defense for it okay when we
had Laura lummer and Bill Mitchell on
debating Trump Vita santis so yeah I
asked Bill Mitchell why are the sandz
people attacking me and he says Laura
lomer tweeted and Alex Bruce witz and I
said Bill stop I'm not Laura ler I'm not
Al BR witz why are they tweeting at me
and he goes Laura lomer and I said I
don't care yeah why are you Tweeting at
me this is what they do they they they
see something from a fan of Trumps they
grab onto it and then they make up
so this is a topical news program When
Donald Trump was challenging to santis
of course we talked about it we talked
about it in numerous contexts there's no
reason to say this other than you're
trying to mislead your audience and act
like we don't care that Trump does these
things when Laura ler tweeted a a fake
tweet we presume from Christina Pasha
that Christina Pasa tweeted the same
thing I said the desis campaign the
desas people are the scumbags they claim
Trump are they immediately ran with it
but Trump doesn't care Tim doesn't care
when Trump does it I said is Laura
lommer on Trump's
campaign and they all they all think
this is the this is why I say okay I'm
done with these people they view
themselves like we are on stage at a
rock concert and Donald Trump is here
and I thought Ronda santis was up here
with us and we were debating what the
next song in the set was going to be I
now realize thanks to the D santis fans
Donald Trump is up on stage we're
standing here behind him cheering him on
and down there in the audience in the
mosh pit arguing with you know with Rick
who's selling cotton candy is Ronda
santis in his campaign and they're
screaming at us on stage and I said ah
why am I even bothering talking to these
people I shouldn't be yelling down to
the to the audience and the fans let let
them watch the show and do their thing
Ronda santz is not a serious Contender
his influencers are not even viewing
themselves as on par with the Trump
campaign so we shouldn't even be
debating him he's done well I think he
is I think that the fact seems pretty
clear that his campaigns just completely
imploded and I've never seen anything
like it in my lifetime probably and he's
never gained I mean Trump is still
polling it like what 60% there no one
has been able to close that Gap here's
the question for the table and I can go
either way but I I'm leaning to towards
one one way or the other the answer is
is this 4D chess from the Democratic
establishment to force Trump to be the
nominee thinking he'd be much more
beatable if he's got that was one of the
things the santis said today you got
this pollster I think this was um who
was this this was uh what's his face
what's the polster's name that no one
cares about anymore Frank Lun was that
was this Lun who said this yeah lunce he
said uh this Supreme Court ruling from
uh uh Colorado Trump is now more likely
to beat Biden because of this yeah but
but I'm saying is that do just because
they're playing 4 d chess doesn't mean
they're good at it so in their thinking
their Normy thinking they could be like
no one's going to vote for a felon no
one's going to vote for blah blah blah
no one's going to vote for they all this
this was their 2016 strategy once we
make right once we make him to be a
white nationalist Nazi no one's going to
vote for him it's going to be clear you
have to vote for Hillary and basically
the message was every single day you
have to go for Hillary you have to go
for Hillary every right thinking person
is voting for Hillary just ask us and
then everyone voted in went into the
booth and raised their fingers said nah
you know trp in swing States not only
does Trump have a lead uh I think he's
leading in seven and tied in two but
some are double digit double digits but
more importantly among people who did
not vote in 2020 Trump holds a 40% lead
in Michigan and like a 27% lead in
Georgia CRA holy crap new voters
swinging towards Trump you know
why the rent's too damn High
yeah you should have him on the show Jim
McMillan if he's still alive it is the
cost of food uh there's a meme that's
going around I love it you know the who
radicalized you meme it's like the NPC
the new one is a guy saying angrily
saying my grocery bill it's a it's a
picture of a receipt yo we I went out to
Ed we went to a Mexican restaurant today
I got we got fajitas guacamole and a
Pusa how much you think that cost $37
what do you think I I I I I don't even
really know what half those things are
maybe it was 36 just for let me I sit
down restaurant we went to sit down7 let
me let me let me give you guys a a
painted picture it was
approximately I don't know what 3 or 400
no 300 ft maybe 200 ft small okay uh I
would estimate
8 to 12 tables okay I know those those
types with fast casual bar style small
Mexican restaurant around here yeah okay
so not a high class sit down we're
talking wood chairs and a table so fajo
I would guess chicken fajitas so this is
chicken breast CH so chicken are $1.95 I
would guess what are the other two
things we ordered guacamole guacamole is
going be 8.95 and a papusa I don't know
what that is it is a stuffed flour
tortilla that's going to be like $6.95 I
would say and plantains plantains will
be what like also uh what do you think
the total cost so 12 13 + 12 25 plus so
like 34 yeah my guess was up there with
34 but now that I'm thinking of
inflation I'm looking at I feel like
it's like $65 $18 fajitas is 57 bucks no
47 47 wow so that's a third more than
than it would have been like not that
long ago
$47.50 not a highend restaurant I mean
I'm not trying to disrespect this
restaurant it was really good food um
but this was a local small like it was a
strip mall a strip M Mex you know why
this makes me so angry and this is why
I'm very like End the Fed and all this
other stuff cuz inflation is a tax on
poverty yes it hurts poor people first
and foremost and and it just drives me
crazy M do you think that you know this
but let me just stress this for the
people listening inflation is good for
the wealthy you you you want to know
what the what the wealthy love about
inflation when the costs go up it means
their net worth goes up yeah right but a
poor who needs to buy chicken and
they're not making enough money they
can't buy that food for their family now
for the for the for the wealthy investor
they're like what's inflation at oh so
what's what's what's my property at wow
my car is up 7% my my house is up 7% the
the the hard assets we own from our you
know insert you know Factory building
whatever all all those are more
expensive now thanks for watching this
clip from the timcast IRL podcast hang
out with us live Monday through Friday
at 8:00 pm. and become a member over at
timcast.net